[Applaudissements]
c'est l'histoire d'un naufrage qui a
coûté la vie à 118 marins voici les
derniers jours du Koursk le sous-marin
nucléaire fleuron de la marine russe le
course c'est son nom est actuellement
immobilisé au fond de la mer au
nord-ouest de la Russie
cette marin russe prise au piège on ne
sait pas de quelle réserve en oxygène il
dispose c'est une leçon pour Poutine
cette histoire évidemment et ses
adversaires il s'en est débarrassé assez
vite par la suite
[Musique]
salut c'est Hugo cette semaine j'avais
envie de vous parler d'un naufrage celui
du Koursk un sous-marin nucléaire russe
qui a sombré à l'été 2000 emportant avec
lui les 118 membres de l'équipage ce
drame retransmis par les télés du monde
entier à révélé au grand jour le
délabrement du système militaire russe
une humiliation pour l'homme qui venait
alors d'arriver au pouvoir Vladimir
Poutine retour sur les 10 jours qui ont
tenu en haleine les médias du monde
entier
nous sommes le samedi 12 août 2000 à
11h28 des sismographes norvégiens
détecte une violente détonation en mer
de barent au large des côtes russes 2
minutes plus tard une seconde explosion
plus importante que la première fait
trembler la coque de l'USS Memphis un
sous-marin américain qui espionne un
entraînement de la marine russe
[Musique]
c'est l'exercice grandeur nature le plus
important depuis la disparition de
l'ours depuis la fin de la guerre froide
en fait on veut montrer qu'on est
toujours la deuxième armée du monde et
c'est cet esprit qui tend la continuité
de l'époque soviétique cette mentalité
qui explique tout ce qui va se passer
après sans nouvelles d'un sous-marin
dont les balises de géolocalisation ont
été désactivées pour l'exercice l'amiral
Popov qui dirige les manœuvres à bord
d'un croiseur regagne la terre ferme à
13h30 le k141 comme on l'appelle
techniquement que l'on connaît sous le
nom de course l'équipe est totalement
inexpérimentée c'est un reflet de la
décrépitude et délicaissances la
corruption qui règne alors dans l'armée
russe et en particulier dans la marine
russe dans les eaux internationales à
quelques 150 km des côtes russes le
sous-marin nucléaire est échoué à 108
mètres de profondeur
le dimanche matin à l'aube la marine
russe affirme avoir capté le SOS d'un
rescapé frappant contre la coque du
sous-marin le course qui est finalement
repéré à l'intérieur les 23 survivants
se rassemblent dans le 9e compartiment
sous le commandement du capitaine
lieutenant-coller snikkov il fait trop
sombre ici pour écrire mais je vais
essayer au toucher il semble qu'il n'y
ait pratiquement aucune chance 10 20%
j'espère comment quelqu'un dire à ceci
salut à tous pas besoin d'être désespéré
collectif
deux jours après l'accident l'armée
russe rend publique le naufrage du
course le commandant en chef de la
marine évoque seulement des problèmes
techniques selon les services de presse
de la marine russe les membres de
l'équipage ne seraient pas en danger pas
de naufrage il parle pas d'accident il
parle pas d'explosion il parle
simplement du fait que sous-marin se
trouve au fond ancien directeur des
services secrets devenus Premier
ministre Vladimir Poutine a été élu
président il y a seulement quelques mois
alors qu'il passe ses vacances d'été à
Sotchi sur les bords de la Mer Noire il
est averti par la marine il faut se
rendre compte quand il a été élu qu'il
est très populaire assez monsieur 73%,
73% de popularité c'est l'homme qui a
été élu sur la vague de la guerre
antiterroriste en Tchétchénie et en
Russie
le course il est pas là il est en
vacances
alors que la marine russe évoque la
piste d'une collision avec un sous-marin
étranger la panique s'installe parmi les
familles de l'équipage
qui mènent des enquêtes de terrain
extraordinaires qui vont aller jusqu'à
soudoyer des pays des pots de vin à
certains officiers pour obtenir ne
serait-ce que les noms des disparus
merde démonté vent de tempête l'image
suffit pour mesurer combien sont minces
les chances de ramener à la surface les
116 marins et officiers prisonniers de
leur sous-marins par 100 mètres de fond
depuis maintenant plus de 60 heures il
n'a qu'à lui précaire est survenue cet
après-midi et la marine russe s'est
lancée dans une course contre la montre
et la mort avec un seul ordre sauver les
marins
Vladimir Poutine qui poursuit ses
vacances au bord de la mer Noire
s'exprime pour la première fois il
reconnaît une situation critique mais
assure que la Russie dispose de tous les
moyens de sauvetage nécessaire quelques
heures plus tard le chef du Kremlin fait
volte-face après un entretien
téléphonique avec le président américain
Bill Clinton le chef du Kremlin a
accepté à contrecœur l'aide occidentale
il a donc perdu des jours précieux son
amour-propre pour être ainsi coûter la
vie de l'équipage
alors que les familles des victimes
attendent désespérément des nouvelles de
leurs proches la colère monte parmi la
population russe
couette
[Musique]
de liberté d'expression extraordinaire
en Russie on peut tout dire tout écrire
[Musique]
maillot votre
oiseau
dans le pays on va montrer un président
qui est incapable de gérer la situation
personne ne veut prendre ses
responsabilités un président qui manque
d'empathie ça ça va pas lui plaire
le 18 août Vladimir Poutine se décide
enfin à quitter Sotchi
alors que l'aide international n'a pas
encore atteint la zone du naufrage les
familles des disparues laisse éclater
leur colère face aux officiels russes
[Musique]
sur ces images une femme en civile
injecte à l'aide d'une seringue un
puissant sédatif à cette mère désespérée
elle est emportée dans une autre salle
inconsciente
sur la chaîne privée
Ort le journaliste Sergueï dorenco
relais les témoignages de famille de
victimes critique à l'égard du pouvoir
tout est fait effectivement pour montrer
que il y a le pouvoir il y a le peuple
et entre les deux il y a un fossé énorme
mais content Vladimir Poutine contact
l'actionnaire principal de la chaîne
l'oligarque Boris berizowski il va
appeler différents organes de presse il
va appeler des réseaux ski pour lui dire
c'est qui ces prostitué que tu as qui
t'a donné 10 dollars pour pour qu'elle
pleure en direct à l'écran ce sont ces
vrais mots pour bien comprendre ce qui
se passe à ce moment-là il faut revenir
quelques années en arrière dans les
années 90 Boris berizovski et
l'oligarque le plus connu de Russie il
est très influent grâce à Ort la
première chaîne de télévision du pays
avec quelques autres milliardaires il va
aider Boris celle-ci à se faire réélire
en 1996 président à la santé fragile
Helsin a besoin d'un successeur et c'est
Boris berizowski très influent auprès de
la fille du président qui va pousser
pour que Vladimir Poutine prenne la
suite il espère bien sur passer à la
tête de l'État quelqu'un qu'il peut
contrôler mais rien ne va se passer
comme prévu les rideaux ski sans
rencontrent très vite mais il se rend
aussi compte que Poutine a bien caché
son jeu et qu'en réalité son projet
Poutine c'est la restauration de ce
qu'il appelle la verticale du pouvoir et
donc la Brou il va commencer entre les
deux hommes ça va sans animer les deux
hommes vont se rencontrer les choses
vont être dites franchement il va lui
dire en gros que si jamais tu fais pas
ce qu'on demande si tu sais pas tes
parts on va monter des dossiers contre
toi et un moment Poutine doit le couper
court à la discussion et il va faire
comprendre à des risques c'est soit ça
soit la prison
[Musique]
après 30 heures d'efforts les plongeurs
norvégiens parviennent à ouvrir le sas
du course
[Musique]
l'intérieur du sous-marin est totalement
inondé tous les marins sont morts
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard les familles des
marins refusent de s'associer à la
cérémonie d'hommage rendu au disparu
Vladimir Poutine reconnaît la
responsabilité de l'État et promet une
enquête pour déterminer les causes du
drame
pour Poutine c'est clair ça ne l'a pas
tué ça l'a rendu plus fort et ses
adversaires il s'en est débarrassé assez
vite par la suite donc les rideaux ce
qui a été exilé les journalistes gênants
ont été limogé Boris berizovski est
forcé de vendre ses parts de RT à l'état
et déménage à Londres l'émission de
Serge dorenko et déprogrammé l'enquête
menée par la marine russe apportera ses
conclusions deux ans plus tard le
naufrage est dû à l'explosion d'une
torpille à bord du course celle-ci
fonctionnait à l'aide de peroxyde
d'hydrogène un combustible hautement
volatile qui n'est plus utilisé en
Occident depuis les années 50 quant aux
marins qui avait survécu à l'explosion
ils sont tous morts asphyxiés au
monoxyde de carbone dans les 8 heures
ayant suivi le naufrage parmi les corps
découverts dans l'épave se trouve celui
du capitaine collénicov dans sa poche
les sauveteurs découvrent sa lettre
merci à tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à poster un commentaire pour dire ce
que vous en avez pensé et à vous abonner
à la chaîne brute et si vous voulez
regarder d'autres vidéos du même style
vous avez le lien de la playlist dans la
description à très vite